so today we're going to cancel
republican congressman and house
minority leader kevin mccarthy mccarthy
is canceled today for engaging in what i
would call right-wing virtue signaling
right-wing virtue signaling is
a special sub-genre of virtue signaling
popular among republican politicians
wherein the signaler jumps into a
culture war issue in the hollowest most
superficial and corniest way possible
in order to signal to other
conservatives that he's down with the
cause even though
he isn't really doing anything to help
the cause at all now perhaps the
greatest possible example of this is
what kevin mccarthy did
a few days ago when he filmed himself
reading
the dr seuss book green eggs and ham
let's check this out
green eggs and ham by dr seuss
i am sam i am sam
sam i am
that's sam i am that sam i am i do not
like
that sam i am do you like green eggs and
ham
i do not like them sam-i-am i do not
like green eggs and ham
would you like them here or there
i would not like them here or there i
would not like them
anywhere i do not like green eggs and
ham
i do not like them sam-i-am
now leaving aside the fact that his
reading voice for children's books needs
a little work reading children's books
is all about and i've done a lot of it
in the last seven years it's all about
rhythm and cadence there's a certain
poetry to it especially with asus book
and all of that is lost in mccarthy's
rendition and it can be canceled just
based on that alone
i'm very picky about the the reading of
children's books
but never mind the real point is that
this is the cringiest and most pointless
display we've seen from an elected
republican
in a long time why is he reading green
eggs and ham that isn't one of the
banned dr seuss books
nobody has taken issue with green eggs
and ham it doesn't require any courage
or boldness to read that book
it's totally irrelevant it's a signal
not to the left
this is not a signal to the left saying
i will oppose you i'm not afraid of you
that's a good signal to send but the
left doesn't give a damn if you read
green eggs and ham
no this is a signal to the right and the
signal is supposed to be
i'm on your side look at me i've joined
this latest culture war kerfuffle
aren't i such a brave boy but the real
message he sends is
i'm afraid to say anything interesting
or valuable about this situation so
instead
i'm going to read from this children's
book that nobody cares about
what he could have done would have
required some guts not much but a little
and would have also had some value is if
he had read one of the banned
dr seuss bucks and the point of doing
that would be first
to just defy the woke mob for the sake
of defying it
and second to demonstrate how political
correctness and wokeness have gone way
overboard and driven everyone insane
he could have read for example as
mentioned earlier mick elegance pool
which is an actual band dr seuss book
and the only reason it's banned so far
as i can tell
is that it uses the word eskimo that's
it
that's really it but eskimo is not a
slur
it's not a pejorative we don't have to
bleep it out when i'm saying it right
now eskimo you can say that it's not
offensive
now it may not be the popular term to
use these days but it's not a slur
and the idea that it's it's so offensive
that it needs to be taken off of ebay
and amazon
and taken out of publication by its
publisher because it said eskimo
is simply ludicrous now it would have
been interesting if mccarthy had read
that book in order to make that point
but then he would have had to say the
word eskimo and that would be a little
too edgy for his tastes
i don't want to say that i don't want to
say the e-word
or he could have read one of the titles
with offensive imagery
and showed the imagery on camera now
that would have been interesting
and he could have made the point that
people 80 years ago you know didn't have
the same sensibilities that we do today
we can't hold them to a modern standard
or view their work through an entirely
modern lens
he could have done that and that would
have been worthwhile and bold and
interesting but instead
he read green eggs and ham a book that
is not in dispute
and that nobody is talking about yet
reading it is the safe
easy uncontroversial way of dipping your
toe into the culture war battle of the
moment
and that's all we get from elected
republicans a bunch of toes dipping
barely below the surface
and unfortunately people fall for this
stuff that he tweeted that out and they
got like 40
000 or more i think likes and a bunch of
retweets
on twitter you know
for what reason i i know that
among republican voters they might say
well at least he's doing something it's
better than nothing
no it's not better than nothing this is
nothing
and there's going to be a lot of this
sort of thing from here on out
remember the republicans had total
control of the government for two years
they had the white house and the senate
for four years
during that time they did basically
nothing they passed a few pet
tax cuts plenty of cable news hits
but they didn't advance the conservative
agenda in any significant way
they didn't even try to advance it in
fact they complain now about you know
big tech censorship well why didn't you
do something about it when you had the
power to do it
the same question could be posed about
every subject the republicans whine
about today
they could have passed actual laws set
policy but they preferred as they always
prefer
to bide their time until they're out of
power so they can get back to writing
big rhetorical checks that they'll never
have to cash
that's their specialty always has been
stand on the sideline and talk a big
game
but the moment their number gets called
and they're out on the field in the
starting lineup
all they do is fall to the turf and curl
up in the fetal position
yelling please don't hurt me then when
they're back on the sideline they're
immediately back to you know talking
smack
man i wish they'd put me in there i'd
run somebody over i tell you
the same old song and dance over and
over again i'm not impressed with it
not fooled by it i hope you aren't
either
and that is why kevin mccarthy is
cancelled
green eggs and ham is not canceled uh
it's it's a great book and if if
you know if the mob ever does come from
greek for green eggs and ham i will be
there to fight for the to the death
on its behalf but right now that is not
the subject
that we're talking about so again kevin
mccarthy is canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated